[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES WILLIAMS:
Welcome to Getting
Started with Material Design.
I'm James Williams.
I'm a Senior Content
Developer at Udacity.
A little bit about me, I wrote
a book on HDML5 Game Programming
that's really, really old, so
you shouldn't buy it because I
only get like $1.00
from it anyway.
I create Android and web courses
at Udacity, and on the weekends
I do Spartan races.
And I got this job by
accidentally crashing a party.
Here's just my shameless plug.
Take our courses.
At Udacity, we have
a bunch of courses
that are available for free.
And my internet is
weird, so just assume
that that's a page loading.
We have a bunch of courses
that are available for free
on Android Development,
Web Development--
and then we also have some
other courses on iOS Development
that we didn't do with Google.
So, go and do that stuff.
So the target
audience for this talk
is a person who has
developed an Android app.
This isn't very
code-heavy, but it
kind of uses some
terminology from that--
understands general
Android layouts,
and contains enough
design to get you moving.
That my Wi-Fi coming on.
Sorry about that.
OK.
Come on.
Are you done?
All right, what else.
OK.
All right, so just a quick
show of hands, how many of you
guys have developed
an Android app before?
Cool.
Oh, and some of you
kids have too, sweet.
For you guys, we also have an
Android for Beginners course
that we just launched
a couple months ago,
so go check that out.
How many designers in the room?
Great, so no one can
correct me if I'm wrong.
So what I'm going to talk about
is actually Material Design,
and then go over
different components
of Material Design, surfaces,
bold graphic design,
meaningful motion,
and adaptive design.
Now on those last two, because
they build a lot on the APIs
that came before-- Material
Design before Android Lollipop,
that'll be kind of a
shorter summary of those.
So what is Material Design?
Material Design is a
design language from Google
that combines elements of
print design, motion design,
digital paper, light and shadow,
to make cross-platform apps.
It is a set of guidelines, so
you'll hear a caveat from me
a lot in this talk that
this is what you should do,
but if you need to do something
else that better fits your app,
then go and do it.
So why should you
use it in your apps?
You should use it because
users yell at you if you don't.
They will post nasty-grams on--
nasty messages on your Google
Play reviews, and
say this app is not
material, and all that stuff.
So use it.
Here's a link to the spec,
and the general design
site from Google.
So the first thing we're going
to talk about is surfaces.
Surfaces are one dp thick.
Raise of hands, do people
know what a dp is here?
Yes, no?
OK.
A long, long time ago, there
was this phone, the T-Mobile G1,
which was introduced
back in 2008, I believe.
This phone looks
really, really bad.
The density on it,
it's 160 dots per inch.
A dp is a physical pixel
on that screen phone.
So that's where dps come from.
So anyway, they're one dp
think, they exist in 3D space.
Because they are a
digital sheet of paper,
they can cast shadows
on one another,
and be moved with
changes in elevation.
They can also be
combined or split apart.
And here is a little
visualizer demo.
Is my Wi-Fi on?
Please be on.
OK, it is not.
I'm going to switch
to the blue stacks.
Sorry about this.
Wi-Fi kind of happens.
Switch back.
OK, let's see if that works now.
OK.
So here we have--
jumping in front--
so we have a material, kind
of a sample material app.
This would be what shows
up in Android Studio,
if you just create a blank app.
So it has a little button
down here, a title bar,
and you can see how this
is several surfaces.
The menu bar here
is its own surface.
This background is a
surface, and this button here
is a surface.
Something that you
shouldn't do, you
shouldn't just automatically
create your own elevations.
The design spec is
very specific on what
heights things should have.
So go to that link
there, and it will
show you the heights of
everything on your screen.
It's kind of a long
list of things.
And-- I'm going to skip that.
All right, so one of
things I showed up there
was a floating action bar.
A floating action bar should
serve as a primary action
for your app.
It's not needed for
every single app.
If you don't have something
that your user's doing
80% of the time, you shouldn't
have a floating action bar,
and there should
be, at most, one.
Floating action bars come in
two different sizes, 56 dps
and 40 dps.
56 dps is the size that
you should use generally.
You can use the 40
dp size if the app--
if the requirements of your
app-- kind of allow it.
It just looks weird to have a
56 dp floating action button.
The strings for those
are normal and many.
So to add a floating
action button to your app,
you'll need to add this
code to your gradle file.
You'll notice here
that it says 22.2.0.
That is for the build tools
of when I made this app.
Right now I think it's 24.4.4,
so use whatever is the latest
and greatest for your app.
So the next thing
you'll need to do
is add a bit of code-- XML code
for the floating action button.
And we can see here at
the top, where it says
"app:fabSize='normal'", that's
saying that's going to be a 56
dp floating action button.
It's going to have an
elevation of six dps,
and when you press it, it's
going to elevate to 12 dps.
Another thing you'll
need to do is,
the FAB requires you to have the
theme derived from AppCompat.
So if you start up a normal
app in Android Studio,
usually it will give you
the top, which is Material.
You really shouldn't
use Material,
because it's not backward
or forward compatible.
Use the one on the bottom.
So if you have a
material-light theme,
you can just change it
to Theme.AppCompat.Light.
So CoordinatorLayout
is a new layout
in Material Design that
allows you to kind of control
how different elements interact
and move around the screen.
Here is an example of
a CoordinatorLayout.
Let me go wide-screen
on this so you
can see it a little bit better.
So the CoordinatorLayout
is our outer-most layout,
and then we have an app
bar layout inside of that.
That app bar layout kit
contains a collapsing toolbar,
which would be a
collapsing toolbar layout,
or something like that.
Have your general RecyclerView,
the replacement for ListView,
of course, and then
your floating action
button down here.
And I can give you a
link for this at the end.
One of the instructors
that I did the course with,
Roman [? Nurik, ?]
created this visualizer.
All right.
Oh, and I forgot I had a demo.
But my Android Studio
did not reload.
All right, so while I'm
waiting for that to load,
I'm going to talk
about SnackBar.
Now, SnackBars are like
a CoordinatorLayout
friendly toast message.
So your toast message
kind of shows up
semi-transparent over
the top of your app,
and it just doesn't
give you contacts.
It doesn't give you anything
to act upon for your app.
SnackBars can contain an action,
so if you delete a message
and you're like,
oh man, I didn't
mean to delete that, you
can have a undo action
and click that.
They can also be dismissed,
and it will move the FAB out
of place vertically
if there is one,
because the resting position
of the FAB and the SnackBar
are at the same elevation.
Let me see if my Android
Studio has started up.
I apologize for this
dead time, guys.
We had some technical
difficulties,
so I had to reboot my computer.
All right, let's move
on for a little bit,
and wait for that to come up.
So the way that
you make a SnackBar
is similar to a toast message.
Before this, you will have
done a [? getViewBy ?]
ID for your SnackBar.
Or, if you're using Butter
Knife or something like that
somehow to get the
widget for your SnackBar,
and you call make with your
message and then the duration
of how long you want it
to show, and then show.
If you want to add
an action to that,
you would add the
function called
TosetAction with
an OnClick listener
and a color for that
text to show up.
Let's see if we're loaded.
Yeah, we're cool.
We're loaded.
All right, so this
is what I was talking
about with
CoordinatorLayout, where
we have a view with an
expanded app bar here,
and we have a
RecyclerView of elements.
CoordinatorLayout automatically
knows to scroll up
and compress that
collapse bar view for us.
We don't really have to do
all that much but to say,
this is what the
expanded size should be,
compressed size should be.
It knows when to scroll
either just the list,
or the list and the app bar.
Any questions before I move on?
All right, cool.
All right, so the next thing
I'm going to talk about
is Bold Graphic Design.
This is the part of the
Material Design spec
that comes from
great print design.
The first thing is the
Gestalt Laws of Grouping,
and this is kind of a trick
from your brain for how
you perceive the world.
So, for instance,
in this room I can
see that there are
a bunch of kids
on the side, a bunch
of young adults.
So I might assume
that they are related,
that they're from
the same school,
because they're
wearing the same thing.
And that's kind of what the
Gestalt Laws of Grouping do.
Based off of proximity
or similarity,
your mind kind of
makes assumptions on
how things are, and tries to
bring order to a chaotic world.
So for a quick example,
we have two views up here.
The one on the far
right looks like it's
a bunch of avatar type images--
circular images with rectangles
next to it.
Just as I was mentioning
before, because all
of the circular
images are similar,
it would be easy to
assume that those
are the same type of image.
Those might be an
avatar for a person,
and the rectangles
are equally similar.
They're probably a
description for a person.
And because the rectangular
ones are close to the avatars,
they're probably
describing the avatar.
There's a lot more
than that, but that's
all I wanted to give you
so I didn't bore you.
Getting back to some kind
of nuts and bolts stuff,
in Material Design, the
layouts are laid out
with an eight dp grid and
a four dp grid for text.
There are a bunch
of key lines that
allow you to line up things.
You can't see it
very much in here,
but for this mobile
screen it expects
it to be 16 dps
from the left edge,
and then there's a
72 dp if you're using
avatars or something like that.
It helps you line up things.
So another thing that you
should be using your design
is great use of color.
Color provides cohesion
across screens,
it makes us kind of feel things.
So in certain countries,
certain colors are not as good.
It's kind of the same in the
US, where if you see a red,
you might think to stop.
You might see a green,
you might think to go.
It's other things like
that, that kind of
tie into the psychology of your
culture and you as a person.
So you should think
about your colors a lot.
So, what if you're
bad at picking colors?
There are two sites that
you can go and pick colors.
One is Material Palette,
where it allows you
to-- if this will
load-- you can easily
select a color palette by
selecting two colors, that
will show up when they do.
OK.
And there they are.
All right, so I could pick
an indigo and a purple.
And basically what it does
is it applies an algorithm
to say this is what your
primary color is going to be,
and the color for your
dark primary color
and light primary
color, and then
also for your accent color.
The other site is Adobe Color--
and I have the wrong thing
there.
So Adobe Color is a website
where it allows you--
it has a giant color wheel.
You can pick one color
and it'll kind of show you
what the complementary color
is, or a contrasting color
is, and stuff like that.
So use that.
If you're not moved by
that and you're still bad,
find a designer.
Buy them a notebook.
They really like notebooks
and hipster stuff like that.
So this is kind of what
Material Palette was
doing with picking the colors.
Material Design--
your colors range
from a 50 value, which
is the very lightest
in that tint, all the way
down to a 900, the darkest.
You should select a 500
for your primary color,
and then bump up a
couple of steps to a 700
for your status bars, down to
300 for your secondary bars.
And then each color also
has an accent range,
from A100 to A700.
Generally, an A200
will work well.
So this is that
same palette that we
selected from Material Palette.
And one of the
other things that I
forgot to mention
about Material Palette
is that it allows you
to download your colors
for the web and for Android.
You can download
it in XML format
to just drop it into your apps.
All right, so typography,
a couple of definitions.
A font, or a typeface,
is a specific style
of writing a set of
text or characters.
A font family is a
group that are equally
influenced by that
same style, but they
might have slight
differences here and there.
And a font weight is basically
the thickness of a font.
The style is generally
whether it's italic or normal.
And-- I will skip
that for a second.
Here's an example of everything
that lives in Roboto.
So all of them have the general
designs-- characteristics
of Roboto-- but you
can see that there
is a regular version, a
condensed, a mono space,
and a slab font.
It also has different weights,
from the thin all way down
to the black and
then bold and italic.
So you can set a
different font in your app
by using the code up top,
if you have a TextView
or anything that
derives from a TextView,
and add the font families
of the different san serifs,
and the text style.
You'll notice that there
is a bold style down there.
Generally, you don't
want to use bold,
just because it kind
of programmatically
makes bold for you as opposed
to a font that was specifically
made for that.
And you can also use a
custom font in your app
by using this code here.
I have a true type font that
I downloaded into my assets
directory, and then
I create the asset.
And then for the TextView,
I'm just setting the typeface.
One thing to keep in mind
is that Unattach-- you
need to do things in
Unattach, because if you do it
in Uncreate-- because of
the fragment life cycle,
there's a small time after
you create a fragment,
before it's attached
to an activity.
So get [INAUDIBLE] will result
in an error and crash your app.
These are all the
different sizes
that are pre-set in Android,
from Display [? for ?] all way
down to Button.
And you can--
[ALARM]
--there's a flash flood
warning, for people on TV.
So, these are all the different
types that you can use.
It kind of shows you that you
can still use one set font,
and have it be very
different and very engaging.
To the far right,
that is the same UI,
but using the same font sizes.
And as it comes closer to me,
it uses different font weights
and different font styles.
The header is using a slab
font and different colors,
and stuff like that.
You can stay within Roboto
and not worry about it.
So my pro-tip for
Android typography
is never use dps for font sizes.
You always use sp-- which is
Scale-Independent Pixels--
which allows your
font to be resized,
if the user has a large
setting or small setting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The grid is in dps,
but the font size is in sp?
JAMES WILLIAMS: Yes.
OK.
That question was,
the grid is in dps,
but the fonts are in sp.
Yes.
The grid that-- you're using
the grid for alignment,
but the font itself
is going to be in sp.
And there is this
weird conversion
of how to convert sp to dps.
It's in the course,
and it's really weird.
But, yeah.
I was freaked out by that
too, so it's no big deal.
You can use Roboto for all
the things in your app,
and all fonts are
not created equal.
Just because you
have a font that you
think is really awesome, it
might not scale down very well,
or the creator of the
font might have not made
many weights of it.
So just bear in mind that.
So just quickly on
imagery, I generally
try to think of it by asking
myself a couple of questions.
Is the brand or product
I'm designing for serious?
Is it playful, is it stylish?
Depending on the answer
to those questions,
is going to determine what types
of imagery I'm going to use.
And for specific concept,
does imagery easily relate?
Is it something very
abstract like thinking,
where a illustration
will work better
than an actual picture of a
person standing at a computer?
And who is your
intended user or market?
These are things to think
about with fonts, as well.
So if you're making a
performance app-- a performance
profile app, you wouldn't
want to use a cursive font
because that doesn't
seem very serious.
It doesn't seem
fast to your users.
Any questions on that
before I move on?
Cool.
So, motion.
Motion should be instructive,
and guide your users
through your app.
This is not the time to say,
look at all this cool stuff
that I can have whiz
around the screen.
It shouldn't distract
them, confuse them,
and it should be
generally orderly.
This goes back into the
things about Gestalt,
where we want to bring
order to the chaos.
And you don't want to
freak out your users
by having all of these
elements coming in
from all different sizes.
Transition Manager was
introduced in KitKat 4.4.
It allows creation of
transition in code or XML,
and it does an insane amount
of the heavy lifting for you.
Have any of you guys ever
had to wire up an animation
by yourself in Android?
OK, so you guys know my
pain of using the old way,
and Object Animator, property
animators, stuff like that.
Here's kind of an example
of it I did that only
took a couple lines of code.
Basically, when you
click the button,
it shuffles the image
off of the screen.
So that actually is doing
a lot of stuff there.
The first thing it's
doing is capturing
the start date of all the views,
then capturing the end state.
It's creating an animator to
interpolate between the two,
and then, based off of what
type of transition type
I set, it's going to say,
OK using those values,
let me make this animation.
So this is the code
that I used to do that.
I have a slide transition,
and I set the slide edge
to the top of the screen so
it's going to slide things
off top of the screen.
Then, down here in
Transition Manager,
I tell it to begin a
delayed transition.
It's using that slide, and
then I do all of the things
that I'm going to
do to the view.
In this case, it's just
telling the image to disappear.
So instead of just
fading off the screen,
it's going to use that
slide and slide off the top.
There are a bunch
of transition types
that were introduced
in API19 and API21.
I showed you slide by default.
If you don't set a transition,
it's going to use
Auto Transition which
will use a
combination of sliding
and I think exploding and
fading, and stuff like that.
It kind of has a set
of things that it
will kind of automatically
move the things off the screen.
Activity transitions-- when
you're moving between activity,
this is another place where
you can have instructive motion
to guide your user by having
a specific transition when
they go into or out of
a specific activity.
So if you have
activity A and activity
B, when you go
from A to B, these
enter-- activity transition
is going to be called.
And when you return from
B to A-- whoa, A is exit.
Restart.
So if I have activity
A and Activity B,
when I'm going from A to
B, A's exit transition
is going to fire and B's
[? interactivity ?] transition
is going to fire.
Then, when I'm returning from
B to A B's return and then
A's re-enter is going to fire.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like there's
a lot of combinations there.
Can you have this jarring effect
if you have a bad exit mode--
whatever-- different insert?
JAMES WILLIAMS: OK.
OK, the question was, it seems
like it could be really jarring
if there are transitions
on both sides,
and if you have a bad
exit or a weird enter.
The answer is yes,
there certainly can be.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES WILLIAMS:
The question was,
do you have to keep
them looking the same?
There are a couple of
things that you can do.
Something I'm going to
mention in this slide right
here-- shared
element transitions--
you can basically say, I want
this object-- or these groups
of objects-- that
exist in this view,
and also exist in this view,
to move, to transition.
A good way to show it to
you is just an example.
Here.
[INAUDIBLE] It's OK.
Coordinated motion--
oh, here it is.
Sorry about that.
OK.
Here's one for a shared
element transition.
I have these sets of avatars,
and if I click one of them
it's going to make a
transition into the next view.
AUDIENCE: Does that do an
exit and an enter there?
JAMES WILLIAMS: That one
was slightly different
because that wasn't
an enter or exit.
That was just a-- yeah,
a shared transition.
I'm basically saying
this set of objects
that I have exists
in this screen
and exists in this
next screen, so I
want you to figure out how
to transition between the two
states.
This is another place
where it automatically
does things for you.
This would be a
way where you would
avoid having to think of--
how is A going to transition,
how is B going to transition?
And just stick to-- these are
the important parts of A that
should transition over to B.
AUDIENCE: Are these
fragments or [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMES WILLIAMS: These
are fragments, yeah.
Let me pull up
that code for you.
I have this code.
Coordinated motion.
Yep, question.
AUDIENCE: Is there a limit
of how many transitions
you can have [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMES WILLIAMS:
Question was, is there
a limit of total
transitions you can have?
No, there is not, but you should
try to do as few as possible.
You should try do just
enough to kind of move things
along, just because--
one of things
you'll notice-- if
you have a person who
has a really old phone, it
might lag on their phone
if you have like 15
transitions firing off.
Good question, thanks
for asking that.
Here's this code right here
that kind of controlled it.
You have a shared
element enter transition,
and this one only
set-- I'm posing.
[LAUGHTER]
So, there's a shared
element enter transition.
It only sets the enter
transition in this example.
It just has a simple
Boolean check of should it
move on a curve, or should it
just be a straight motion back.
That's another
thing that I didn't
mention before, you should
try to move things on curves
as much as possible.
Going back to slides, did that.
Quickly, on interpolators, this
also goes with transitions.
You can
[? programmatically ?] code
how you want something to move.
There are a bunch
that exist in Android.
These are kind of the three
that you should probably
use the most.
You can kind of notice, if
you have a long duration
of 300 milliseconds, it makes
your app look like it's slow,
but if you have something like
300, it looks zippy and fast.
So generally, you should try
and keep your transitions
to be about 300
milliseconds, give or take,
and kind of adjust from
there to see how it feels.
Quickly, on adaptive design--
how much time do we have?
Oh, we're good.
You should think about
your content first, and not
your device.
What I mean by that
is you shouldn't
code for a specific
device, and instead
let the content tell you
where things should break up.
If you have limited
developer resources,
having a break point at 600
dps is a good starting point,
but there are many, many
others that you can have.
So in material
design spec, there
is one for very small screens.
It says-- let me see
if I can blow this up.
Nope.
Doesn't work.
Image.
There's like 480-- 600--
[ALARM]
There are a bunch
of different sizes,
so a good starting
point is start with 600,
and then, depending on your
user base, and whatever form
factors you want to
support, do more or less.
There are a couple different
strategies for managing space,
so when you're moving from
a smaller screen to a bigger
screen, you can reveal
more of the content
that you were showing
on the smaller screen.
You might do a
master detail view,
where you show multiple
fragments on the screen.
You can also re-flow the content
to just use more of the screen,
or, if neither of those
work, you can just kind of
expand the white space
around your content.
And dividing is the
opposite of [? revealing ?],
just splitting your UI
into multiple fragments.
To implement your
break points, you
should be using your qualifiers,
like Landscape and Portrait,
and the ones at the bottom
are for specific densities.
You should not use the
small-medium-large qualifiers,
because those are really
fuzzy and cause problems.
And that was it
as far as content
I have, but definitely
open for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]